so last time where we left off I was
slacking off and I was saying some
interesting [ __ ] about doing things but
I really wasn't planning anything let's
just build this swinging chip and I get
this over with so where should this
thing be I yeah right if you could stop
doing all that terraforming stuff then
and I could actually place rice yeah
that would be great I might actually
built rides on this hill but I think
I'll leave that room for a roller
coaster of some sort so I'll build a
pirate ship over here or something yeah
that does make sense now think about it
okay so PI chips can be here and we're
just going to continue with the path and
let that go over there and add a cube
for the pirate ship over here AR doesn't
look too bad and nicely spread out so
here is the swinging ship which i'm not
going to rename because nobody cares
about names and we need some hedges in
this thing so we're sure that hatch be
it's gonna be about here and over there
I guess yeah right there
and then we're gonna place a dolphin
over here because we like dolphins very
nice and this finger is a lightweight we
already have that over there what am i
doing dude I need to go I need to get
balloons because I I want my guests have
balloons but then again I could research
this department but then I actually have
the risk of getting something stupid
like information stuff because I don't
want that yeah let's just not do that
let's just go to foliage and play
somewhere foliage because I need foliage
in my life and let's just use this bush
instead of the books that i've been
using for years now and play some of
these trees no actually cacti have a
place any cacti over here just going to
play skat tight nice okay so this area
doesn't really need anything but I'm
still gonna add stuff because I just
don't want empty areas that's just me
yeah not too bad I'm going to continue
that hedge and that'll be just about
good so I'm Nicki Minaj is still looking
strong 10,000 profit per hour how much
can you buy with one profit I don't know
and what we need is some go-carts
because we need some mario kart or as
yung lean would say it I've no clue yung
lean says it ok so whoa stop that okay
that was a stupid window don't do that
again band rollercoaster tycoon one okay
so we're gonna go here and what am I
even doing stop that perhaps I for a new
roller coaster or something no I don't
have anything hmm and I played all this
sort yeah I really am out of options go
courts or have wait note i need to add
another handyman
that would come in handy man and I
wonder how dynamite blast is doing 5,000
per hour your week Nicki Minaj's getting
more profit than you are and it can be
noisy as an example for all of us okay
so what should we do the mine train is
all about fast smooth twister track and
can be improved considerably about anak
tunnels hmm yet you added so many twists
and fast elements and tunnels to this
thing yet you're still not making as
much money as this simple nicki manaj
wooden roller coaster ease yeah I'm
beginning to doubt your expertise roller
coaster tycoon I am just going to do my
own thing and built this this mega track
are you kidding me mega track look at
this look at this is or even though
there's not even one 40th of the entire
map I can do better than that and holy
she is there a queue for this thing how
many swings yeah yeah bring that back to
nine I don't care about the test results
okay as long as you're making me money
as long as you're looking sexy over
there I need more benches up a new
people sure are walking slow when they
have a drink with them oh this guy wait
wait wait stop that options show real
names of guests ok I've got Aubrey and
Maria and and Sylvia on that's a lot
like my name hmm such an honor so let's
build this this go cards and get some
court action you know that's better over
here yeah let's go up the hill I stop
that why do I keep doing that and i
didn't i didn't really plan this
hmm
okay that kind of works I suppose wait I
want to make this fancy I want to make
this fancy so I'm going to do this yeah
baby and then I need to go up one more
and then we're over there might be a bit
weird but I salil I kit and then we're
gonna add that are nice such go cards
and of course I do want to change this a
bit I feel like I [ __ ] why's my land
over here I don't like it when the land
is over there for some reason I just
can't work with that I'm going to make
this not yeah that bricky Egypt kind of
text to these detective that they ripped
for a roller coaster caen tues Egypt
theme if i'm not mistaken and there we
go we're good to go I might build some
houses but building houses in while ago
second one is not really my thing I mean
building with terraforming is a nice
idea and all but i am not really the
biggest fan of it let's just put it that
way so what else do we want to do think
i'll just actually i'll just do like
this yeah i'm more terraforming up in
this thing this thing is starting to
look more ugly and awkward by the second
knowledge asst change all of this should
have done that and one go because now i
took more terraforming costs but
whatever terraforming costs are part of
the thing how I also want to raise that
nevermind
okay so that did cost a bit of money but
think it's worth it it's now I have this
entire area and I can do this now that's
not too shabby for a go-kart track I
think it's pretty realistic though God
tracks are usually not that spread out
so you probably shouldn't make it to
spread out and I'm going to do this like
that and just add that and color this
not stone texture now I do have one
would text you over there but it's not
very big and it's probably better than
having a random stone pillar over there
okay so we're done with this thing we
don't have any ugly supports which is
what I want and it looks good so this is
going to be this is a yoshi's island
because yoshi is lund because it you can
clearly see that it looks like it so
that we go and we've got 11 cards 11
cars whenever flow to your cart and we
need an entrance yeah right I'm just
going to put the entrance over here and
the exit over there and then just do
some funky [ __ ] with it like that
yeah that'll work and then i'll just do
this and then it's all connected very
nice and what's with the UH there we go
and it still doesn't work okay then have
it your way it's um it's gonna be your
shiz is lond okay also nice another
fountain because we're dubai and more
hedges yeah definitely and of course a
palm tree
and of course a little fence over here
we because we sure don't want people to
jump on the roller coaster and some
bushes because I am a freak and I want
every single area to be covered with
nice greens and foliage and this is why
I suck at desert maps speaking of
foliage the go-kart shouldn't look a bit
better than this we don't have any
scenery so we'll just have to improvise
and add some random stuff I don't think
the clock is over here nope hmm could
actually add some flowers yeah and that
does look nice and then I not think of
that before ok so I think some flowers
everywhere I like it some flowers over
here as well some of these and some of
these very nice and now what we did an
extra a handyman I think because there's
lots of vomit on the paths ah we finally
have the suspended roller coaster which
is annoying Costa type but it's a roller
coaster nonetheless so might just work
now this go-karts track is going to be
the hay hedge fest because all of the
all of those little worm is all things
cliffs faces is something whenever you
call them in this game are going to have
a hedge oh wait that doesn't work well
then now we're finished Wow okay then
I'll just add edges over here I suppose
I do want to theme this ride please
it's not the best thing ever but it
works and do we need some hedges over
here yeah that would look pretty cool
hey at least the edges do kind of bring
it Yoshi's Island feel with it I don't
see how but I guess it works and yeah
that's pretty much it when it comes to
that however I do want to add some trees
as well so I is a couple of trees and
what else what we need is some some of
these sexy bushes Oh sexy no wait we've
already used those these ones perhaps a
pretty fat but that doesn't matter in
before trigger alert being fat doesn't
matter I never said that being fat is a
bad thing I'm sorry i meant that i felt
like thin bushes would be better over
here perhaps just because i felt that
way but and these these are I mean these
are more voluptuous ones also work okay
whew and let's see we need some some of
those these yeah oh nice like it my park
is stunning way to green how can any
gardener keep all of this all of this
greenery in such a desert I suppose the
answer is Dubai okay so they go kart
track and damn its popular number of
laps is gonna be one stop this because
the line is way too huge and I people
bothered no thats so we can just turn up
the price crank up that price yeah boy
crank up that prize mean and why Yoshi's
Island come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on come on
my I have the best value pike oh yes
what's my park entrance price yeah
that's free I suppose that's best value
yeah but still a prize is a prize so um
thank you so we're going to place an
invert and I'm going to do it over here
because last time when i did this it was
an absolute disaster and it was
horrendous so I'm just going to do it
again okay so flight of the Phoenix is a
nope that's not gonna happen we're just
gonna build our own [ __ ] and i think i'm
going to build the station into the this
little thingy over here so i'm going to
have to terraform all of this uh let me
first see how much loan i can get wait
you can't raise it like that only 15,000
oh damn that's gonna be a problem I was
expecting to be able to load more oh
well I what's uh what's the goal for
this scenario even so I didn't even
check that the goal is in year three six
hundred and fifty guests well I'm gonna
make that anyway can't really worry
about that okay so it's gonna be hard to
fit a station or an entire coaster for
that Messer over here but I'm gonna try
it okay so here comes the station oh
that's one big station I'll leave some
room for the brakes at the end and go
down over here and I don't know go up
over here oh that does work
and then we'll just do this not enough
cash [ __ ] yes I have enough cash
look at that there's plenty of cash okay
so here's going to be an arrow suspended
swinging coaster as all of the coast
owners would call it however the rest of
the world prefers to use the term flying
coaster or swinging coaster or coaster
that's pretty fast and underneath the
track I think that's the most common
term coaster that's underneath the track
roller coaster in the way now you're
kidding me come on it's not in the way
over there hmm well apparently is it is
according to roller coaster tycoon and
rollerCoaster Tycoon is king so we'll do
something about this actually no no I'm
not going to do that let's try this hell
yeah and it works however then I can't
have any supports and then I still can't
have any supports well if I remove the
hedge still can't have any supports if I
do this then it does work actually yeah
i'm just going to do this like that then
hmm oh you're not the best thing to do
I'll just try see if I can go over this
which I can't i can if i do this but
that looks weird hmm i'm having some
first world problems over here trying to
build my roller coaster roller coaster
cone it just doesn't work hmm so what do
we do with this then well first of all
I'm gonna change the colors because this
hurts my eyes merry go rat ha merry go
round I'm gonna gonna fire you okay so
um red and black well what do you know
that actually does look pretty cool yeah
I'll just keep it for now however I have
no clue what to do with this thing hmm i
might just keep the curves normal like
that and then go up over here and then
do something with it
now that also works I wonder if that
looks good and it does look pretty good
as well so why not you know let's go for
it however I wouldn't like to actually
make this a bigger perv or something I
don't know what if we do an S bend no I
can't do that hmm oh that's a shame on
that case I'll just try and do something
about that not it also some try
something else good just try going
underground really ok so the until hedge
is gone they're going underground with
an inverted coaster is pretty much the
worst thing to do but it works so you
can't even go on the ground there on the
ground however if I no can do that
either why not what are we doing I can't
I can't even add a small our way I see
why hmm don't do that either can't do
that either well it's like my only other
chopped ship option what only other
choice Wow is to just go down and do
something with that yeah yeah
here you go sure I'll raise it sure I'll
raise it you happy now okay so it's all
raised now and it should be fine okay
let's see can we can do that yeah that
looks better I do want these underground
parts to look good as well it's very
important so on this thing needs to look
good as well mmm that's good
oh that actually just made it worse but
now i'm going to change it back this
looks good enough safest park in the
country ah while this coast is going to
change that there's no way I'm going to
be able to add an entrance if I do that
oh wait I can't actually over here
entrance over here and exit over there
yeah that does work are nice roller
coaster in the world and the what mm-hmm
it's too late for me keep brain fighting
I don't like it when people fight in my
office so I need to stop that oh damn it
i only have 300 euros left well that's a
bummer however i should be able to
finish this thing pretty soon i'll work
on some small things first ok so the
entrance however i do want this to look
sexy and good so i am going to
terraforming that work you know it works
and we need that entrance but i just
change the window oh there we go that's
what i need it because yeah if you
didn't know yet i am playing roller
coast i can in windowed mode actually
because I tried full screen but it would
just keep glitching or it wouldn't
record or it would like and this is
actually the least likee way to play the
game no wait entrance entrance is over
here yes exit is over there thank you
very much and then I'll just add this
little path thank you and it's little
path thank you
and then we'll connect up to the rest
and then we got that done and I've still
got 300 euros left time to add some
small things some benches over here
especially down there's a lot of vomit
over there and I'm going to Oh normal
funding well that's actually pretty good
and I'm i think i'm only funding on
roller coasters which I don't want
anymore I want thrill rides and gentle
rides as well and regardless of oh wait
its steel mini roller coaster that's
actually very honey that's something
that I kind of need I nice i'm gonna add
this and i think all of the vomit is
gone over there yeah oh no this thing is
actually doing like it's actually it
makes 1,000 an hour that's not that bad
Nicki Minaj's still going strong 10,000
an hour so that's good oh right now I
know the main reason why these things
are so expensive is because this costs
58 but as soon as you start adding a
curve it's going to cost you 254 / curve
that's an entire flat ride for one curve
these things are really expensive really
if you look at this look at this 3000
and upwards but it's even more expensive
than all of these other things way more
expensive so yeah that's that's pretty
much why these things are so annoying to
build especially if you go underground
because going underground is even more
expensive hmm maybe I shouldn't do this
but I just like the look of this more so
i am going to add a big one like this
plus i am making money at a decent pace
so i'll be able to finish this at some
point however right now i just don't
have the money to do anything which is
something that I must admit will raise
the land
how much money do I have left I can't
even go underneath that yeah there's not
enough money for that but it's pretty
much time to end the episode here so
yeah that's it pretty swell I'll work on
this coast in the next episode as well
so see you then I guess bye